I'm David shlessinger and I'm chairman
for China of Thomson Reuters because I'm
chairman for China I'm on the China
Council here at the agenda council forum
here it's an amazing venue we have 79
different forums all discussing with
themselves and then with each other it's
like speed dating for policymakers for
business people for world leaders and in
that speed in it's clear that in the new
model china is key but the question that
were wrestling with and I think the
question the China itself is wrestling
with is whether China's power comes with
leadership will tryna take its new
economic strengths and actually be a
leader either regionally or globally or
within multilateral institutions that is
really a key question for the world as
we go forward is how we take economic
power how you take physical size how you
take the developing ethos that China has
and combine it into true leadership but
in this speed dating that we have here
in Abu Dhabi it's very clear that all
the other councils want to know where
China's will is all the other council
want to interact with people on the
China Council and try to come up with
some answers as to how China plays a
part in the new war that we're creating